what should we kick off on the topic of
delusion in in 2021 does anybody want to
well aaron was on quite an interesting
show with some
some females on it where it kind of came
up so i thought if you've got any
thoughts from that aaron
yeah you're just down in miami doing the
fresh fresh and fit pockets yeah
yeah i guess it's a perfect example uh
so around fresh and fit and um they had
uh three gals on
uh and they're kind of regularly
bringing women on and interviewing i
think it's a good thing because
it shows you the insight into women you
get from the horse's mouth
but in this particular uh episode there
are three gals
and they're all in 30 plus
and i asked them like okay do you want
to get married
where does getting married rank in your
priorities uh today
and why aren't you married now and
they're all attractive women there's
certainly
there have been good men that have
thrown themselves at their feet there's
no doubt about that
and uh it's one thing when we hear it
through
news articles or as ryan points out you
the the internet is a very finance it'll
dredge up
all the monsters beneath the sea that
were always there we just get to see him
this time
but when you talk to real live women and
you realize it isn't shtick
you know the dating profiles we see like
oh is that just the worst of the worst
it's like
no you start getting a real bass line
you put your finger on the pulse you're
like
this is real like we've been pretty
accurate
in women's disinterest um
in men frankly and so the the women
roughly in
you know marriage was either dead last
or third or fourth place but uh
not once was it number one i even said
like well you're 38 when you know what
the hell this is about this is about
it you know bottom of the ninth two outs
what are you doing
why come first and it was just this
complete disconnect from what is love
what is required to have a
healthy long-term relationship or a
marriage uh
where one guy was like well me my career
my dogs
dogs your freaking dogs there was a 29
year old gal
uh majoring in hotel management
and uh she's an attractive young gal and
yeah but my career comes first and i
gotta get established i'm like you're 29
what have you been doing for 11 years
yeah and uh what we what we finally came
to the conclusion is that because
not just the internet but the nature of
men and having disparate sex drives
um men and society have really kept
women
inculcated in this bubble where reality
and menopause and biological fact
and common sense not to mention the
philosophy and the morality of like what
is love like don't you want to fall in
love with like
dude you're you're you you're you're the
most boring person on the planet to
yourself because you know yourself all
the time
do you not want to find value in others
do you not want to be
actually human and fall in love and it's
you could see it where it's this
no we're focusing on ourselves we're we
do not
yeah yeah the statement is they'd like
to get married
but you saw that real world where
they're like
nope we don't have to get like men are
kind of i'm not i want to put
words in their mouths me roll can better
speak for me
but they really don't think to
find attract and convince someone to
fall and compel someone to fall in love
they think that's like a
a weekend process like you just again go
to the husband's store get yourself a
husband off the retail box
and there you go so uh it was
amazing to me but you could you could
just see how society men wanna you know
bill burr
uh you know women are surrounded by this
tornado of misinformation and no one
corrects them
because we want to [ __ ] them and you saw
that on display
on that so they are so far removed
because everyone will tell them what
they want to hear because
either guys want to [ __ ] them or
governments want their votes
or businesses want their money and there
was no getting through them no gates so
there was
it was a very good bit of anecdotal
evidence as to how disconnected the
women of that age are
you